Wall Street is celebrating the longest
bull market ever that means it's the
longest period ever without a decline of
20% or more now that's kind of amazing
because we have a trade war going on
right now we have an implosion in Turkey
and we have volatility all over the
place the last longest bull market
occurred in the 1990s and it ended with
the tech bubble bursting now what does
today's long bull run mean for the
current markets I'm Ken Brown I'm the
editor of herd on the street at The Wall
Street Journal and we're gonna go back
over some of the high points and low
points of this 3543 de bull market since
the bull market started on march 9th
2009 stocks are up 320 percent and if
you go back to the start date you can
see why bull markets start during
terrible times and this is no exception
it was the heart of the financial crisis
unemployment was right at its highest
level of the financial crisis the other
thing that helped drive up stocks was
the Federal Reserve which was basically
printing money to get the economy moving
that had the effect of boosting asset
prices like those of stocks and real
estate the road to the record has not
been smooth in fact two years after the
bull market started it almost ended
abruptly after credit agencies reduced
the US government's credit rating we had
two of the worst stock market days ever
because of that there was another ugly
stretch in 2015 and 2016 caused by China
devaluing its currency that sent ripples
through markets all over the world with
the election of Donald Trump in November
2016 the bull market gained new steam a
big corporate tax cut boosted profits
and a big stimulus got consumer spending
more how will it end bull markets start
during terrible times but they end
during periods of euphoria the last two
bull markets ended when the tech stock
bubble burst and the housing market
burst so investors right now should be
suspicious bubble bursting bla bla bla